[Musique]
tout le monde se souvient de la sphère
d'aval histoire sordide alexia cette
jeune femme assassinée par son compagnon
johnatan qui durant des mois avait
demandé aux enquêteurs de trouver le
coupable de ce crime devant les caméras
de télévision avant d'être finalement
condamné à 25 ans de réclusion pour le
meurtre de sa compagne
il a reconnu avoir étranglé son épouse
alexia après une dispute aujourd'hui un
nouveau rebondissement vient réveiller
cette douloureuse affaire
cette fois ci c'est la famille d'alexia
qui a décidé de faire un recours en
justice pour obtenir des indemnités de
préjudice de médiatisation nous avons
fait valoir cette médiatisation dont
nous avons au départ été victime
en effet selon eux le fait que cette
affaire et été aussi médiatisée leur
aurait porté préjudice
m portejoie l'avocat des parents
explique c'est un véritable drame pour
les parties civiles que je représente
aujourd'hui de voir chaque jour
les commentaires les émissions sur sur
alexia c'est un coup de poignard
à chaque fois les parents d'alexey
réclament 370 mille euros pour ses
préjudices pour recettes à cause de
johnatan et la façon dont il s'est
répandu dans la presse que cette affaire
a été si médiatisé nous sommes une
demande qui ont fortement irrité l'un
des avocats de johnatan d'aval alors
préjudice de médiatisation comprenez
vous la demande de la famille d'alexia
d'aval maintenant il ya une condamnation
il a été reconnu coupable hier il a fait
il est donc en prison et maintenant bah
c'est une histoire de gros sous
ça vous choque gounon québec vous vous
êtes je suis un peu désolé c'est juste
scandaleux le préjudice de novia tease à
sion les parents d'alexia d'aval autant
je veux bien au début de la faire aucun
tous ces images de john savage qui leur
tenait la main après durant le procès
n'ont pas arrêté dans la presse même
pendant le procès la mère d'alexis rien
n'arrêtait pas d'aller sur le parvis du
tribunal s'exprimait devant la presse a
participé à tous les documentaires etc
etc
elle c'est elle qui a mis en place cette
médiatisation du côté du côté adverse on
n'a quasiment pas entendu les avocats
donc c'est juste je suis sale une jambe
de dire cette somme pharaonique
non mais non alors il faut quand même
savoir non ils n'ont ils risquent pas
d'obtenir la cour d'assises forcément
n'est pas une banque
mais il faut savoir qu'au niveau des
sommes
quand il ya meurtres d'enfants et d'un
des indemnités comme on appelle pour les
parents ça tourne autour de 80 mille
euros et pour les tentes autour de 50000
euros
oui parce que les parents sont
indemnisés là on parle de médiatisation
mais ils vont aussi demandé à d'aval une
indemnité d'avaliser en cuisant pour 25
ans et oui être le cas ici oui mais ça
c'est pas à dire c'est pas son enfant un
peu bizarre
il demande la gloire de réclames et donc
c'est 80 mille euros que l'on peut
demander aux parents mais la famille
proche les tentes aussi peuvent être
indemnisés et demande ça on peut obtenir
50 mille euros donc là les hommes de 300
800 mille euros c'est pas c'est à dire
un lieu commun mais honnêtement ça ne
changera rien exactement ma part aussi
moi je trouve que c'est une aberration
totale je suis désolé mais c'est honteux
c'est une honte cette pauvre jeune fille
qui est plus de ce monde aujourd'hui si
elle voit ça dans ol doit donc c'est ça
quelle horreur entre son mec excusez moi
et c'est par an aujourd'hui
mais comment on peut fixer le jour
comment on peut même penser à ça tu
domines donnant ce match alors on
réfléchit pas ça c'est vrai que
maintenant je dormais ça d'accord et je
peut on alors que l'on attendait à cause
de ça il n'a pas de bar tabac qui l'ont
vendu et dont ils travaillent pas ce
qu'ils ont raté des journées de travail
ils peuvent demander des indemnités
parce qu'ils en ont l'air non mais c'est
là mais ce que je voudrais comprendre
c'est que quand il est aussi reportage
ou là vous avez peut-être c'est beau de
voir des mois des veillées
ils ont pas là ils ont été payés quand
même il est alors sert au paiement des
routes spécialité tour des infos
précises et selon moi rien et
disproportionnée lorsqu'il s'agit du
meurtre d'une jeune fille ils ont
demandé huit cent mille euros maison
notman dit demander ni demander un
million d'euros symboliquement en
revanche évidemment c'est totalement
baie de biscayne
jamin voilà est-ce qu'ils se sont servis
les médias non je crois c'est maso les
médias qui sont servis de jeu le nombre
de revues de presse de reportages et de
sujets qui ont été déçus ressources à je
pense que les médias ont suffisamment
bénéficié de cette affaire par rapport à
ses parents alors notre âme était elle
répond oui je le comprends dans le sens
où les médias ça peut autant apporter
qu'un pacte et lors d'une enquête
je pense que j'ai compris les parents
sont issus de classes moyennes donc
peut-être qu'ils veulent de l'argent
pour se barrer sur une île déserte parce
qu'ils ont plus d'anonymat
à l'heure actuelle ou alors pour mettre
leur argent au profit des familles enfin
des personnes cibles de violences
conjugales
maintenant la justice tranchera mais
c'est vrai qu'il faut prouver qu'un
média a réellement leur a réellement
causer du tort après c'est vrai que
c'est compliqué de trancher mais je
pense qu'il préférait largement à voir
leur fille que de l'argent et on ne
savait pas qui était de 9 en tant que
c'est vraiment analyser prouver et tient
la justice je pense que chez tôt ou tard